all right welcome ladies and gentlemen
Chris waters here on the GameSpot stage
super excited for an extra-long preview
demo of middle-earth shadow of Mordor
and joining me on stage to die have
totally just freak on your name in the
long time we've had to talk together and
like hang out I feel so bad it's not
tallien it's Michael - platter from
monolith studios and Middle Earth shadow
of Mordor really impressive showing
yesterday during the press conferences
nominated for a GameSpot best of e3 2014
award and I you know you're trotting the
game out getting people to see real
solid demos of it now in action how's it
feel to have it out there I think and
what's really exciting and I think you
know a bit different it's every single
time we do a demo he it's different so
like we literally can't you know can't
show it the same way twice if we wanted
to so let's make your demoing job a
little bit nicer you know there's some
new stuff cropping up every time
especially like you know day one it's
fine but by day 3 like we yeah it's
really gonna be very very different from
having to do the same thing a hundred
times it's very cool alright well we've
got a long demo to play through so let's
just get right into it and Michael why
don't you set the stage for us
where is tallien at this point in the
game and what's his goal so the game
takes place it's set in between The
Hobbit and Lord of the Rings okay I kind
of like both of them it's kind of a
standalone story in its own right mhm so
at the end of the hobbit
Sauron gets defeated by the white
council he gets driven out of his
Fortress of dull Guldur and he returns
to Mordor yeah he's been away from there
for 2,000 years and over that time
Gondor has been occupying Mordor so
basically it's kind of the Knights our
on comes home and that's where our games
actually yeah yeah I'm back yeah all
crap the arc Lord back between going to
crap up the whole place and so that's
where we that's where we begin our game
and at that moment when he returns
Gondor has been guarding these things
for two millennia and obviously over
that time with not as much going on the
guards fallen off it's down to a
skeleton crew and your tally and you're
one of those Rangers and when Sauron
returns you're slaughtered along with
you
family along with the other ranges on
the gates but Saran's return also
awakens this other ancient spirit who
has a very very deep tide of
middle-earth Lords or the rings of power
and a very ancient grudge against Sauron
and then that spirit is awakened and
resurrects Italian and then together the
two of you go deep behind enemy lines
and kind of take the fight to Sauron
back into the realm you sort of once
guarded in the fortifications you once
inhabited now being turned to saurons
use as he builds his army and Mordor
yeah and then of course sixty years
later we're going to see them as the
black gates of Mordor they're going to
be in garrison but you know that's a
long way in the future and sounds got a
lot of work to do to build his forces up
so you know you can make a big
difference to the fate of middle-earth
by how much you can get behind enemy
lines and really mess with his mess with
his plans every last or counts man and
so so this is in a way it's a you got a
little bit of a an origin story for
Sauron you know not his origin visa via
his Lord of the Rings incarnation but
you're sort of telling part of his story
in addition ditalion story yeah that's
something we're really excited about you
know there's there's a number of
different characters from the books that
we bring in but I think the one we are
really excited about developing is
Sauron because a lot of really what you
see in The Hobbit is the necromancer so
he's a very distant sort of character
and the same in Lord of the Rings he's
pretty abstract as the great eye on the
Tower of barad-dûr we get a few little
references to him Gollum refers to the
the black hand of Sauron but we really
don't get to develop him as a character
and talking actually put a lot more into
him as a character into his background
into his history and in particular one
of the intriguing things about him is
the rings of power he worked together
very closely with the elves on that so
he wasn't always this just total
incarnation of evil he there's enough
depth and nuance and you know to
actually deceive the elves and work with
them so we get to explore a lot of his
backstory and more of his motivational
ring a power storyline is so much about
corruption of people and erupted the
creation of this evil as opposed to you
know we just dug up this horrible evil
from deep beneath the mountain it's no
we sort of brought this evil ourselves
in the hearts of man over the course of
millennia almost and so we got a little
glimpse of sort of a set up there and
now we're right into it and branding
WarChiefs
seems to be the task at hand so yeah
what we've seen basically the character
we just met is Marwan and she's a queen
whose deep behind enemy lines in Mordor
she's the leader of basically one of the
sort of the holdouts of gondolas kingdom
that were in there and she's drawing you
deeper into Mordor two reasons one to
help the resistance there and secondly
to learn more about the identity and the
mysteries and the power of this this
race and this is sort of the key to how
our game works a bit because she's given
us our story objective we can do more
than just hunt down and kill and
assassinate our enemies we can bend them
to our will we can actually you know
make an army behind enemy lines but kind
of what's important is that how we go
about doing that is going to be
completely different for every play like
you're really free and how you approach
and here so here we see one of those
inflection points where you see where
the player experience is going to
diverge because you got this whole
rogues gallery of war Chiefs and you're
picking the ones to target yeah exactly
so there's two things one I mean we're
obviously short cutting things here to
show you here today yeah in the real
game there's a big chance that a number
of these guys that are the leaders in
the war Chiefs are going to be people
you've met two three four times before
they might have started as a sort of a
load a lowly guard as an archer on a
tower and they fought and battled and
backstabbed their way up to here so your
arch villain your boss can be completely
unique to your game some of them you
might have met before but they'll be
different as well
but every single time you get a
playthrough they'll be different and so
you know here for example this guy the
executioner it's not just them waiting
in the world for you they're out there
actually living in the living world
they're hunting you as you're hunting
them they're
actually going on missions there
battling against each other to work
their way up there the English variants
in them getting more powerful as you do
yes oh and that's the thing it's partly
about you know we're really trying to
create villains here which is partly
about making them all play differently
because they have different strengths
and weaknesses but partly about them you
know sort of having different
personalities and identities we're
really trying to make super villains
basically and you know having they have
their own origin stories all of which
they have scars that you've left on them
and the thing that really pulls it
together is they remember so it's really
a way of putting the player at the
center of the living world because if
you've done something awesome whether
it's ruined this guy's feast or saved
him from certain death in an execution
or turned up on his greatest fear
whether that's a monster or whatever I'm
just going to remember that and respond
to it and he's personality adapts to
that as well he can become either
terrified or enraged by the things
you've done to him so it's it really
plays out in a meaningful way for the
gameplay and so it's into it you're
talking a lot about you know how these
these villains and their personalities
change but I was reading a preview we
have up on GameSpot written by Randolph
Ramsey when he got to play the game and
what struck me is how he is sort of
feeling towards the villains evolved
because you know you say you sort of you
can encounter these guys a few times his
encounter was he got cocky he went into
a melee this lowly orc killed him he
respawned
but when you come back into the world
time hasn't stopped yep you come back
into the world that thinks you're dead
and that you got killed and so that orc
was promoted to captain and so he came
back and he's like you know what I'm
gonna go after that guy and like he
tried to go after that guy and he blew
it again and so that ork got promoted
even more and so the Nemesis Building
was on his side as well as as in the
game and that was fascinating to me I
mean really you know there are a few
inspirations for that one is the sort of
grudges you can get in against another
player in multiplayer sure you know
actually making a is and NPCs that
double down on that same feeling that
you are
you know building up relationships with
them and and secondly you know that
they're remembering you they've we want
to create the feeling that they feel
like that as well yeah and then also so
often like I think one of the you know
often one of the least fun things to do
in a game is to die because if you die
usually what that means is okay you get
to go back and do the same thing you
just did and failed again
you know failed at ya which maybe wasn't
fun maybe it was but you've got to try
that in order to proceed and very much
in a way that's in line with how we see
the Ring rates in the film that helped
and that ability to resurrect we wanted
to turn death into an opportunity so and
that works in a few ways one by as you
said by killing you you know it
obviously gives them a lot of status
they've just taken down what is from
their point of view the biggest villain
immortal aha so you know that moves them
already their heroes to their to their
mates so they move up but secondly it
creates that opportunity for vengeance
and for you to hunt them and build your
legend as well absolutely now I I want
to get into sort of some of the combat
mechanics we're seeing play out here but
I've taken your questions via Twitter
folks so tweet them to me my half my
handle is CT waters that's waters with
two T's and use the hashtag GameSpot III
poison monkey one wants to know can you
set rival or you know sort of turned
armies against each other in your sorta
orchestrations and manipulations yes so
we have basically we didn't want to over
complicate it in the sense you have
there's really two factions there's
Sarah on Tommy uh-huh and then there's
the guys you bend to your will I mean to
some extent it's like Sarah man his way
that he believes to take down Sauron is
to fight force with force and to build
an army of author acai in order to take
on the Dark Lord so
you know it's similar so we don't have
multiple sort of sub factions within
that but once you actually dominate and
send one of these guys to your will I'm
can absolutely continue to increase them
in power so you can send them on mitad
missions to improve themselves and make
them fight duels against other orcs once
they battle all the way up to actually
become a war chief you can set rival war
Chiefs against each other they'll have
you know large-scale battles like we see
in Kira tunngle where they'll actually
bring their own bodyguard so you really
can build up and farm and build your
army and then ultimately take those guys
that you've built and farmed up and
leveled up against your ultimate enemies
which of these black captains and
they're sort of our ten poll villains
the guys that are personally responsible
for your death and the death of your
family at the start of the game so kind
of escalates but we really want you know
to carry that through that you build
your army behind enemy lines and you
really do take that against the Dark
Lord Erik or Michael ah that's sort of
so the overarching story as you alluded
to there is one of vengeance this is a
revenge fuel tale this is a this is not
a guy trying to you know prison necess I
mean you know he's not his primary goal
isn't preserve the last light that
remains or like fight against the
oncoming tide like that's but that's
part of it yeah but also personal
revenge is a huge part of that and
that's not a narrative that you see
terribly often in Tolkien war so I mean
you know how did how is it to sort of
weave that into this world that story
you guys are writing that revenge fueled
Justino plot into the the greater
fiction yeah I mean it's a really good
question one of the things that's
amazing about talking is he does cover
this incredible spectrum of tones and in
some way the deeper you go back into the
law uh-huh into the first Age into the
second Age so some of those really epic
heroes people like baron people like
feein or you know these are the guys
actually do start off driven by revenge
and they really do start out as
as as bad guys as bandits almost as
criminals really uh and I think some of
that earlier law is is really closer to
the kind of myths that inspired talking
as well these myths like Beowulf and
these nautic myths that that are sort of
pretty dark so you know I think in that
sense we are sort of very very true to
an authentic to Tolkien plus we're also
very much in line with those heroes like
borrow me borrow me is not someone who
was conflicted about the idea that all
or Sara man for that matter who's
conflicted about the idea that the way
to take down darkness darkness is with
ruthlessness I only mean necessary yeah
and talking's obviously pretty clear
that ultimately that's not necessarily
the way to to that you're going to win
or be victorious but but borrow me is
interesting because ultimately he is a
heroic character because he was ready to
sacrifice himself ready to actually do
himself for what he perceived was the
greater good soon you know that that's a
journey and an arc that we're really
interested in exploring as well alright
well I want to blaze through some of
these questions from Twitter we are
getting a ton of them thank you folks
for sending them in keep them coming uh
so some of these you're probably not
gonna be able to answer put them in
throw them to at you anyway through
Memphis andrew barnett wondering are any
members of the fellowship going to
appear in the game not directly so you
know we I've been very much like The
Hobbit and Lord of the Rings we want
characters who are you know important to
the law yeah to appear when it's
appropriate but we also didn't want the
Forrest Gump just having them cameo in
there for the for the sake of it so
there certainly are characters from Lord
of the Rings and The Hobbit that appear
and the similar vein czar wants to know
are we going to see some elves in the
game I mean obviously it's a very Orkin
sort of man heavy setting yep those
aren't the only two races in
middle-earth
we're going to see multiple races
including elves in some really important
roles all right we've got questions
about the about the open world James
Cole wants
sort of you know are you just right
running roughshod over the plains of
Gorgoroth here like how far and wide can
you sort of span in the open world so
mortal is going to many hundreds of
miles along each side yeah so it's not
continuous
you know it's divided into into regions
so the opening part of the game is
around Gorgoroth is around who do new
black gates Keira fungal the fortress of
der things and that's sort of a large
open space there and then what we're
actually showing here which is the sea
of known is another completely separate
zone that you've traveled to sort of
many hundreds of miles so it's a number
of distinct zones and areas all right
we've got questions from people MOOC any
clearly have some some Tolkien blower
background up curious about using The
Silmarillion as source material but
pulling in any of that sort of world
building stuff as well yeah that's a
great question as well so we have the
rights to the Hobbit and The Lord of the
Rings and the appendices and the thing
is within those there's a huge amount of
information and depth in regard to all
of the history and characters of
middle-earth as well so we you know we
could really can draw on all of that
because you guys have a lot to work with
yes there's a good little daunting
sometimes to like delve deep and just
see the breadth of this world they're
talking created you know I think it's
almost like doing a historical story
historical fiction it's like you're
creating a world and a story in a real
place yeah and in the same way if you're
drawing unreality in history it's big
enough and expansive enough that you can
tell your own story so you're not
restricted in that way you know I almost
can't imagine a type of story that you
couldn't tell within middle-earth it's
you know it's as big as world war ii
like its mass above it is huge so you
guys got a significant research
department over there modelling yeah we
got that in pretty hardcore fans and
middle-earth enterprises are great so we
have a lot of people fact-checking and
the other one that's great is our Kia
site
you know the fans on there so fantastic
like we can just obviously there's
threads in there breaking down
discussing everything there you go folks
you want to tip the scales and Middle
Earth shadow of Mordor get yourself into
some deep token lower forums haha
alright let's now let's delve into
combat proper because we've been
watching a lot of it we haven't really
talked about what we've been seeing sort
of specifically in terms of mechanics
actually here's a choice moment that I
think you're going to encounter more
than once throughout the game to kill or
to dominate so this is actually I
haven't been watching exactly what's
been going on but we've got to a point
where there's a war chief he's down on
his knees he's defeated we got two
choices we could kill him at this point
and that's the end of it and then we can
go into some of our upgrades which were
our runes and how you actually customize
your weapons or we can dominate we can
bend him to our will so it actually
becomes our minion your choice and you
know obviously sort of one of these
factors that affects the way it's gonna
it's going to branch out are we calling
for the kill
yeah are you getting the thumbs down
thumbs down yeah very good
all right so you got do a little work Oh
Derek his head is flipping around hey
guys these last words but there's a nice
room we get so okay so what happens then
he's eliminated bang oh great I had me
watching so there was another that
executioner we met earlier he's been to
our will he was a bodyguard of that guy
so that space that's created allows our
follow our branding going to move up and
take that position move into the
position of power so that's one of the
ways you can kind of take over the
Warchief start to build your army and
now some other guys have turned up at
this fight as well and so give us a
little just a little breakdown of the
kind of UI elements the on-screen
indicators that are giving us the
important information you're going to
need to succeed in combat yeah so of
course above his head this guy that the
livest Rinker yeah that's turned green
basically green in
in a game that's a language for Intel
gathering Intel learning your enemy's
strengths and weaknesses is really
important so there's enemies in the
world who are who are worms who have
information you can grab them
interrogate them to learn their
strengths and weakness of these bosses
but if you want to get that information
from one of the captains one of the
bosses you've got to break him down and
weaken him first so when that skull
turns green he's ready you know he's
really dominant thus the the crown and
the blue we can see on the other guy
that was round to the left that shows
he's ours so that indicates that the
power of the rapers is dominated this
guy as well yeah I saw that a second ago
you did a little race mode and sort of
like the blue flash came over him and it
was that gaunt skeletal skeletal really
freaky looking wraith face-up that we
saw in Lord of the Rings movies I how
much you guys relying on or drawing from
Peter Jackson's movies to influence the
visual style of your game you know I
think so we worked with those guys right
from the beginning and everything goes
through them for the approvals and so
you really had that as a starting point
but one of the things everyone's been so
encouraging on is you know don't don't
make a movie game make the best possible
game that you can make and to be fair
you know that's what that's what the
movies are they're not just the book on
screen they're these amazing films so we
really wanted to take the inspiration
from them of doing the best we can with
this material in our medium and so yeah
I think it was a starting point but I
think we've sort of evolved into to
something that has its own own flavor as
well but the the power of the ring race
whether it's in the books or the film is
the power of fear and domination and
bending your enemies to your will
so that idea that concept of what power
means whether it's a ring of power or
whether it's the Wraith was was
absolutely the influence for what sort
of power we can give you as the player
to build your army behind enemy lines as
well you guys didn't go that Tom
Bombadil route drawing your powers from
nature and living in seclusion Tom
Bombadil is awesome he's one of my
favorite characters he's the one guy in
the whole books that gets the ring and
just tosses it in the air
all sucks all right outside of all of
this you know whatever even Gandalf
Galadriel they can't even take the ring
for a second so he's pretty awesome
and the other quote I like about Tom
Bombadil is which-which talking said was
even in even in a world of myth you've
got to have mysteries you know you've
got to do something new you've got to
surprise people and that's really
important to us as well you can't just
it would be so inauthentic to talking to
just rehash things people have seen
before
it's really authentic to these stories
that you do introduce something new
that's still consistent and authentic to
the to the case um you know player
something people something new to
discover within that world exactly you
know so the race as we interpret it it's
not exactly maybe some things have been
seen before but it's completely
authentic between within what's possible
within the law and I think the more
people learn about it you know the the
cooler that's going to be as well all
right Mike I'm going to dive into some
more Twitter questions this one I've
been getting a lot from Starkiller from
Joel Evans from any number of folks on
Twitter wondering about gameplay modes
and specifically any kind of multiplayer
it says the campaign is single-player
we're really focused on the
single-player experience
but in terms of kind of social play and
competitive play we have a couple of
things we have submissions called
vendetta's so because your enemies that
you're creating are going to be so
unique to use if one of those guys
killed you can actually create a side
mission in your friends game where they
can go and hunt that guy down who killed
you they can achieve vengeance for you
and if you do you know you both get
upgrades and rewards for doing that no
that's kind of a that's kind of a cool
way to make that sort of get playoff
that revenge pipeline is like open jury
yeah you know Joe sending the Xbox
message yeah you know the showdown to
reflect that and so on and then the
other thing our challenge mode we've
sort of got a challenge mode that's
quite unique to a Nemesis system as well
so it's a bit different different
difficulty levels we have a version of
Saiyans army we have some really tough
war Chiefs we planted in there some
captains and then you can basically can
you can you clear that with our
dying it's like a hardcore mode how fast
can you do it how many points can you
get and then we have leaderboards for
that challenge mode as well right on so
giving people a way to sort of take this
combat system and take their own sort of
unique character building they've
customized and really put it to work in
a competitive way I don't know it says
to sort of plot it get their friends or
at least try to take their friends
scores down and of course the ability to
share videos and now I think there's
going to be so many moments of that from
our game that you know people are going
to want to show to each other and share
these really unique kind of boss fights
that they're only going to see in their
game well Michael we're coming to the
end of this demo time and that means we
have some good news and bad news the bad
news is like a ton of the questions
people were asking about combat
mechanics about customization of your
character loadout about all those sort
of stuffs you guys were seeing pop up
about you know gaining little buffs and
gaining skills we didn't really get into
that this demo fortunately Middle Earth
shadow of Mordor is going to be coming
back to the game spot live stage shows
every single day of e3 we're going to
have a demo tomorrow and on Thursday so
keep an eye on the game spot schedule
see one that's coming along come on back
and we'll get to those questions
hopefully because there's certainly a
lot to talk about as we found today and
the game is just looking really great
mark thank you very much appreciate it
really pleased you could come on looking
forward to seeing you in the coming days
and learning more about Middle Earth
shadow of Mordor thank you